it's hard to believe the world could
ever run out of fresh water
even though we live on a blue planet
only about three percent of earth's
water is fresh
of that only one percent can be used as
drinking water and that is threatened by
climate change and growing populations
more than one billion people from madrid
to mumbai struggle with access to fresh
water every day
growing up in and around the ocean is
what led me to become a marine ecologist
today i travel the world photographing
stories about marine science and
conservation to help people better
understand their connection with water
so i've always been really aware of the
water i use but i want to know what more
can i do to save water well here in the
u.s the average family uses about 300
gallons of water per day that's like
running a shower for two hours straight
is it true that more than a third of the
water we use goes towards keeping
ourselves clean it is it's time that we
realize that water won't always just
flow from the faucets we really need to
rethink our relationship with the water
that we use and waste every day
take washing your hair for example much
of the water used in the lifetime of a
shampoo or conditioner actually happens
right in our showers or baths and don't
forget the environmental impact of
heating all that water so having a
shorter shower and turning the water off
while using products is a super easy way
to make a big difference
look for products like shampoo bars that
are easy to rinse and over their
lifetime use about 20 percent less water
than liquid shampoos
and you could use products like leaving
conditioners or no rinse conditioners
that can help save up to 25 gallons of
water per tube
so that's using products what about
making them some companies are really
helping here by recycling and reusing
their water for cleaning and cooling in
the manufacturing process
no rinse conditioners leave-in
conditioners solid shampoo bars and
recycling water in manufacturing are
some of the steps garnier are taking to
save water as part of their green beauty
journey
we can all take one step of our own to
make our world a little bit greener
[Music]
[Music]